[Musique]
bonsoir petit ami quelle belle journée
je sais que vous êtes allez vous
promener et que vous avez vu les jolies
fleurs qui poussent dans les jardins péo
watson ou les oui mais oui gros ours peu
ça leur fera très plaisir des sens vite
merci patron à tout à l'heure
eux auront un gros ours apporte une très
belle surprise un petit louis et à
mirabel
je ne vous dis pas ce que c'est mais
c'est très bon
[Musique]
ça va bien dans très bien monsieur mais
il faut que je vous laisse car membres
aux mimos va bientôt arriver
me voilà justement bonjour est ce que ta
part tu n'as qu'à une petite surprise
qui se mange la peur doucement les
enfants là et voilà les premières
fraises c'est ma soeur emilia qui me les
a envoyés on va mettre du sucre dessus
tiens voilà ici
ou homo que ce pont qui donne ne peut
pas prendre toutes les grosses l'eau oui
mais je marche de sa vie mais moi je
voulais pas
c'est pour toi gros sous un halo patron
au look haut ce que tu blagues plus de
petits coquins qui mangent les fraises
pendant ce temps là il en reste encore
tant mieux
beaucoup de si beau oui merci merci
aum
[Musique]
alors alors oui il est autrement j'ai je
veux pas ce monsieur marge de sable
[Musique]
c'est vrai ça n'est pas une blague cette
fois ci un loger coûte gros ours à
l'appareil
c'est vous patron allô allô
mais mes vues n'y a personne au copain
de p'tit louis et les fraises
tous sont les frères ils ont tous mangé
toutes les grosses toutes les petites
aussi haut
les belles fraises de ma soeur et
milliard dépendent les bons coups c'est
promis parce que je ne vous en
apporterait plus simple et si on va
chanter notre jeu
viviane et vient de nous